at first I did the b in apartment 23
after yes that lasted a couple Seasons
yep two seasons you love that show I do
I would do it again in a second Why
didn't it get picked up why it was a
listen it was on ABC it was right before
things the metrics sort of changed like
we got canceled for numbers that now are
considered like massive hits right
um it was kind of like scheduled badly
it just was kind of dragged around by a
smeared dog didn't really but it
was also very edgy and we really pushed
the envelope the writing was way ahead
of its time and it was just one of those
like great little quirky shows that
probably probably served everybody
better by just being two seasons yeah
because it's like you know cult
following people love it I love it I
will watch it and laugh at every line
because the writing is so good